salut les amis et bienvenue sur le
doublage de le monde de dori le nouveau
film événement disney pixar où j'ai la
chance de prêter ma voix aux dauphins
bélugas du nom de b les jeux vous
présenter un petit peu l'équipe c'est
parti alors vous avez ici
bell est un qui s'occupe de tout ce qui
est projection d'image
ça y est bel et bien tu t'occupes de
quoi toi et moi je m'occupais de tout ce
qui est gestion et autonome elle 6,74
mais oui mais moi quand même mais mon
film voilà merci daury nemo est ce que
tu as un petit mot pour notre
téléspectateurs
merci nemo voili voilou les copains bon
ben voilà c'est l'équipe du film le
monde de dori et on sera tous en salle
retrouvez-nous le 22 juin pays sap